♪ Standin' on the corner ♪
We have all come here together.
Over there, Andy Warhol.
♪ Suitcase in my hand ♪
We have this chance to combine
music and art and films all together.
We're sponsoring a new band.
It's called The Velvet Underground.
♪ And me, I'm in a rock 'n' roll band ♪
["There She Goes Again" playing]
That was my first time in New York,
and it was appalling.
This place is filthy.
Cinema, money, parties.
It was outrageous.
People came because
the cameras were running.
They thought they could become famous.
At the center of it
is the exploding art world.
It opened your eyes
to a lot of possibilities.
["Venus in Furs" playing]
We started getting a following.
But a lot of radio stations
wouldn't play our stuff.
The sound, not only was it new,
but it was radically different.
We were studying natural harmonics.
♪ Shiny, shiny ♪
Lou's music was very heavy.
Everything he does in that
crackly voice of his resonated.
♪ I am tired... ♪
That weirdness, it shouldn't have
existed in this space.
His music sounded
like nothing else.
And all of a sudden,
he would stop like that,
and the audience
would be dead silent.
The Velvet Underground
had hypnotized them.
♪ One, two, three ♪
♪ Anyone whoever had a heart ♪
Lou was always very clear
that there's no difference
between being a writer of the book
and a writer of the lyrics.
The artist is not with society.
He's different.
I was interested in communicating
to people who were on the outside.
♪ Sweet Jane ♪
They were going to blaze a trail...
which eventually they did.
♪ Sweet Jane ♪
Good evening,
we're your local Velvet Underground.